great teams that go on to win it all in
any sport have a handful of things in
common an incredible drive to be the
best an organization that supports them
one or two star players to rally behind
and the fact that they all live in the
same house wait what
that's not true at all who wrote this
while drawing comparisons between
traditional sports and competitive
gaming is pretty common there might be
nothing more uniquely eSports than the
gaming house also known as team houses
these nerd dojos began popping up in
Korea towards the end of StarCraft brood
war in the beginning of Starcraft 2 and
the motivations behind them were pretty
simple organizations would move their
players under the same roof where they'd
work eat live and hopefully improve
together okay so we got ammo at that
other gun will prove it typed in CJ that
he can t jump in table the Lord about
did so do game use on the video and if
you already think this sounds like a
situation that could easily become a
disaster you're right but we'll get to
that although players could communicate
through the internet the teams with
dedicated houses found there was an
advantage to sharing the same physical
space this is to you looking out at 109
then I'll tell you about it illicit play
how do you pay how do I pick dan
community to nail cut another day a
kebab with kisses dick
that's it dick big about it and for a
long time the record pretty much spoke
for itself in StarCraft Korea was
utterly dominant to the point where
Western prose began making the
pilgrimage to these houses to live and
learn from the best so what is the the
main benefit of living in a house like
this um for me it's like not having to
do a lot of chores and having food
provided and where I can just play all
day and not have to worry about stuff
and then also having other people around
me where I can watch them play or if I
need to talk to Greg about something
he's there or if I need practice
partners like forge ESL or whatever I
can practice with them and [__]
Jesus as eSports continued to grow in
the early 2010's
more North American organizations began
to see the value in team houses that
houses most of the members of the
Starcraft 2 professional gaming team of
evil geniuses but it wasn't just
Starcraft teams that were getting scrim
cribs as League of Legends continue to
surge team solomid set up their first
gaming house in Long Island New York
with the hope that it would take their
roster to the next lover was lost after
working so hard how can we be better how
can we be a better team and we all the
way all thought of gaming house was
essential to deep gain that by 2013
gaming houses were no longer the
exception but instead the rule and with
Riot Games launching organized leagues
in the West that were played on location
it only made sense for players to live
in close proximity to one another
although gaming houses were conceived
with the goal of improving performance
it quickly became clear that they were
also useful for developing clout
the cloud team houses were able to
popularize both players and
organizations because the environment
was a gold mine for producing immediate
accessible content
the copses actually came to her house
like two times now now one for the
common oxide alarm one for this fire
alarm and counsels to those choices also
there's a lot of stupid optic gaming's
Call of Duty House was built
specifically upon this idea with the
team's owner Hector hex Rodriguez
stating that the organization didn't
just want to produce star players but
gaming celebrities you to join a guys in
a chat today we're ready video and you
guys are gonna be getting an updated set
up tour at the optic house on top of
competing for titles and call of duty
optic built their brand and community
around streaming whatever games were
popular at the time and regularly
uploading prank videos now despite the
entertainment value that gaming houses
produced as they grew in popularity it
became clear that they didn't always
offer ideal living situations after all
it's a house full of young adults who
may never have lived away from home done
their own laundry or cook their own food
I'm sorry are you eating turkey chili
off of a frisbee even in the best days
of a Starcraft there were indications
that this type of arrangement could take
a toll on players
someone on a testify needle that was
pretty docile for most people
then ultimately this environment became
notorious as a breeding ground for all
sorts of stupidity
for instance TSM's the odd one had a
diet that consisted mostly of junk food
and soft drinks which basically led to
him contracting a health condition
resembling scurvy I've been and I've
been sort of sick lately but I think I
mean slightly better what is the [__]
pirate junk food was the source of
embarrassing drama in heroes of the
storm as well back in 2015 the community
was left shaking its collective head
when tempo storms roster was partially
torn apart by a stolen bag of Funyuns
look at these and if dealing with
headaches caused by Funyun theft
accusations wasn't enough at least there
was the threat of scorpion ambushes to
distract you from it but sometimes it
wasn't the immaturity of the players
that was the problem it was the house
itself this was the case when the
tainted mines League of Legends roster
moved into a gaming house in Australia
on top of lacking the essentials for
actually practicing like functioning
internet and pcs the building didn't
have basic amenities like laundry or air
conditioning the only thing that made
the situation worse was how management
handled it at first they were like
making promises like this is gonna be
fixed by that dates but they would never
reach their deadlines and then we
communicated directly with the org and
they would tell us to go through the
manager but every time we went through
the manager nothing would get fixed so
how can you keep the advantages of a
gaming house but avoid their penchant
for chaos well some organizations have
attempted to find a middle ground
creating facilities where players can
practice and work but another where they
can live preferably on their own let's
go in here one of the earliest adopters
of this strategy was cognitive gaming's
heroes of the storm team the players
lived in apartments in threes but then
played and worked in a private room at
internet cafe in San Jose they offered
to move us out to San Jose put us in
apartments and give us a space to work
out it we can just like leave the
computer for a little bit go outside we
have friends that are right outside our
team with unsurprisingly this model
actually works because you know most
people actually enjoy not living with
their co-workers
sorry Matt that's true and today some
orgs have taken this concept to the next
level for example Team Liquid has a
pretty swanky facility in LA which
accommodates their different game
rosters so we made a decision to move
away from the antiquated gaming house
centric model of having all of your
staff and athletes living in a
single-family home it was leading to
more depression and anxiety for athletes
surrounded every single day pretty much
every hour of the day with your
coworkers and without that separation of
kind of personal and work it was leading
to mental fatigue teams in China have
ridiculous training facilities to look
no further than OMG whose home base
looks ready to blast into orbit at any
point on the other end of the spectrum
are the insanely over-the-top living
gaming houses like this enormous
secluded Manor that C is org M 19 used
for their boot camp or more famously
phase clans cloud house a decked out
mansion that takes the idea of
associating the team brand is a
lifestyle to a whole new extreme why do
you got shoes on what are you doing you
know do you have shoes on and with all
these organizations competing against
each other for talent and the attention
of fans gaming houses have transformed
into a flexing contest for instance
optic sold csgo house in Chicago
included an outdoor hockey rink and
indoor pool while hundred thieves fort
night team has a nine thousand square
foot mansion equipped with a piano that
no one can play properly
[Music]
it's about as bad as it can possibly get
for the foreseeable future these two
types of gaming house will probably
coexist and in some cases blend together
but as eSports continues to develop
we'll have to see if social clout and
competitive performance continues to
drive a revolution in the way pro gamers
practice and live that they couldn't pay
me enough for that to happen
[Music]
all right so it's day 23 of living in
the score eSports house and I don't know
how much more this [__] I can take I
mean Shawn he just corrects everyone's
grammar all the time
Colton he's just watching anime all day
and that idiot Colin he just leaves his
mustache trimmings everywhere have you
seen my phone is miles I haven't seen
your damn Funyuns definitely not and
that [__] idiot Colin keeps leaving
his mustache trimmings everywhere